so like is there an issue or not I'm
like hello Linda Tripp you might have
told me that you're recording me when we
were talking as friends yeah I'm Monica
Lewinsky without the semen on my dress
well there's there's like residual
issues just because we broke up like we
were we were in love and we broke up
season three when we started season
three everyone hated Lisa Barlow so it
was like season 13 for me
there was a lot of rumors going around
about Lisa in a moment my drunk ass in
lingerie gets the rumors out it's
rumored that one of your
that has the Jazz tickets
that you've been involved with are you
crazy I'm not crazy in the moment I
needed Heather to validate that she knew
what I was talking about with the rumor
I had never heard that specifically ever
said in my life and I just said I've
never heard that she's like you're a
liar and I said Whitney you're acting
drunk you're acting yeah you called me a
liar you pushed me into the window
because
[Music]
it is definitely not about what we're
talking about right now this is like the
Strider broke the camel's back yes
Whitney do you feel like she's done more
for Jen than you yeah I think that's
what was brewing because she is watching
you ride for someone who's been guilty
you'll lie to your face and it's ruining
your relationship with Whitney I don't
appreciate being gaslit by Whitney I
know that I show up for my friends I
know that I have 100 shown up for
Whitney I have never not had your back
publicly or privately when you came up
and in the middle of a trip that was not
about you not about you plus stirring
the pot not about you making a moment
talking about Lisa
okay well then you chose the TV show
over over now
it's a compromise of character no but
that's true too I have to agree with
Heather if you did it before TV moment
I'm gonna agree with Heather
I never thought you would compromise our
friendship
ever and you did
I know we believed as Mormons a lot of
crazy
but this rumor is too dumb too damaging
for me to sign up for it my Integrity as
a gossiper is affected by this rumor if
I just like blindly sign up and say it's
true
it's not true Heather cares more about
looking good on the show and having her
hands clean she handed Mia grenade took
the pin off let me blow up and walk away
before any shrapnel hit her that's why
it hurts so deeply because we're family
where I went wrong was I pulled our
outside of the show friendship in
because I needed you oh
Ash if when do you never have
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations
listen we all know I like a good little
back and forth but every now and again I
get sick of hearing it so I'm done with
this one okay pick it up later because
it's giving me indigestion
I know
ha
[Music]
foreign